welcome to horace hobbies the channel
where we discussed the latest tech news
and dove into newest tech products today
we're taking a look at the top five
things that you should consider before
buying the intel i7 8700 k but before we
delve into that make sure to hit that
subscribe button if you guys would like
to see more videos just like this one so
starting off with the number one why are
you even building a PC is it for editing
is it for gaming is it for modeling you
have to be able to identify why you're
building a PC in the first place in
order to be able to determine if the 87
or K is worth it for you for example if
your main focus is gaming and the 8700 K
is a great choice and will provide you
with a great performance however if your
main focus is productivity related like
editing then a rise and see if you may
be better for you because I put score
count advantage also it is important to
consider what performance you need in
what you are doing for example if you're
gaming at 1080p then you may just need
the 80 600 K and it may be wiser to
spend more money on the GPU than on the
8700 K however if you are rendering in
4k and you want to go with intohe then
you probably want to go for the 8700 K
because CPU is very important when it
comes to editing so make sure to think
about why you are building a PC and what
performance you need for it moving on to
number 2 are you okay with spending a
lot more than you would with a rising
build let's be honest Intel does have
some good performance on the gaming side
of things
however reisender will definitely
provide you with much more value for
every single dollar that you spend if
you want the best gaming performance
available then yes they YZ 700 K is
where you should buy however it is still
important to consider if you're okay
with spending a lot more money than with
the rising build and it is not just the
C for you you also have to spend a lot
more money on the motherboard and you
have to buy a CPU cooler on top of that
furthermore MD is much more lenient with
their backwards compatibility to let's
say in two years you want to buy a new
CPU then you won't have to buy a new
motherboard
however with Intel you probably will
have to so as it is clear it is a lot
more expensive
to build an Intel based PC so that's
definitely something to take into
consideration on to number three when
are you planning to buy because the 9700
Kay is coming really soon and it'll beat
the performance of the 8200 K if you
guys didn't already know intel is
planning to launch an 8 core 16 thread
coffee-like chip later on with this need
to be ninety platform this year now
granted this cpu and its motherboard
will be more expensive but if you're
really going for performance then this
may be something to consider as well
also if you are waiting for the holiday
season to buy the 8700 k then it may
just be better to buy the 9700 K because
of all the huge discounts and deal that
will be going on during the holiday
season so the price difference may not
be that big so make sure to keep in mind
that such as CPU is coming very soon
aunt number four how long do you plan to
keep your chip for example if you want
the best gaming CPU available and you're
planning to not upgrade for like the
next four to five years then 8700 K is a
great choice however if you know you're
going to upgrade in the next two to
three years because you want to have the
newest tech available then you may want
to just go with the risin because AMD is
much better with backwards compatibility
and so it'll be a lot cheaper for you
also if you plan to keep your CPU for
the next four to five years then you may
want to go with the octa-core processor
because that really is the future and
that moves me on to number five which is
that the 87 or K may have become
outdated really quickly like the 7700 K
did AMD is definitely making huge
strides in the cpu market and they're
continuously adding more of course not
just to their enthusiast thread
repressive use but maybe even to their
mainstream CPUs that's right next year
with rising third generation we may see
12 core and maybe even 16 core CPUs so
as a result going forward AMD and Intel
will most likely release higher core
Khan CPUs for the mainstream platform
and as a result games and programs will
be redesigned to be able to better take
advantage of high korkin CPUs and
because of that a hexa-core processor
may become outdated in just a couple of
years
so if you're planning to keep your CPU
for a long time then you may want to go
with the higher core count CPU and just
wait for the 9700 K or go with the AMD
rice and 2700 X so those are the five
things that I think you should consider
before you buy the 8700 K did I miss
something make sure comment down below
because I do read all my comments and
I'm curious as to what you guys think so
make sure to post your thoughts also if
you guys like this video then make sure
to drop a like and hit that subscribe
button if you guys would like to see
more videos just like this one
but until next time bye
[Music]